have a box of these vinyl gloves Julia
Mook is 16 weeks pregnant and working
from home in New York she's expecting
her child in September and keeping a
video diary of her life under lockdown
she says she's trying to take enough
precaution to protect herself from
covert 19 but she's worried I am
concerned about how it would affect me
being pregnant and I am also concerned
about how it's going to affect impact
the birthing process and also having a
newborn as hospitals around the world
struggle to cope with the rising number
of patients many women are worried about
giving birth at a time of a global
pandemic potentially I'll be going into
labor without like a support person or a
family member you are a visitor but then
on top of that delivering in a place
that I don't know and with someone I
don't know the World Health Organization
says pregnant women with symptoms should
be prioritized for testing while there
is no evidence yet of transmission to
the fetus new mothers who have symptoms
are being urged to take precautions they
should cover their mouth and nose so
remember they are infectious they can
they could put the droplets onto the
baby so we don't think they'll transfer
it through the breast milk but you could
transfer it through the the normal way
that everybody else is transferring this
virus through the nose and the mouth so
wear a mask at all times when you're
dealing with the baby and again be
absolutely rigid about washing your
hands ad agencies say the pandemic and
lock downs may disrupt access to
life-saving sexual and reproductive
health services for millions of women
worldwide especially those in poor
nations the epidemic has impacts on
multiple levels particularly when it
comes to access to family planning and
safe abortion care
when women don't have access to these
services we see big rises and unplanned
pregnancies as well as unsafe abortions
so we can expect to see devastating
consequences for women and girls around
the world because of this lack of access
to reproductive healthcare services
although severely restricted life hasn't
stopped because of this pandemic but it
seems to have made things more difficult
for women's health and their well-being
Priyanka Gupta al-jazeera